[Musique]
bonjour antoine sa ligne à merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous en direct ce
matin sur rtl france le vaccin moderna
qui est arrivé aujourd'hui sur tout le
territoire le ministre de la santé a dit
qu'il lâche minerais dans les zones où
le virus circule activement hors
marseille n'est pas concerné pour
l'instant est ce que c'est la bonne
stratégie selon vous il est difficile de
parler de stratégie vous savez le vaccin
moderna il arrive ce matin sauf erreur
de ma part à hauteur de 50 mille doses
ce qui est finalement totalement
dérisoire et les zones où le virus
circule mettre massivement sur le
territoire sont nombreuses je suis
moi-même député du val d'oise où les
chiffres sont aujourd'hui
particulièrement inquiétant plus que la
manière de répartir le vaccin sur le
territoire on devrait se poser la
question du volume de vaccins dont on
dispose et de savoir pourquoi
aujourd'hui nous n'en avons que 50 mais
il faut pas oublier que ces deux
injection de ce vaccin qui sont
nécessaires et qu'il faudra 120 millions
de doses
je pense que au delà de la stratégie de
diffusion
il faut aujourd'hui essentiellement se
préoccuper sur la manière de se procurer
ce vaccin le maire de marseille on l'a
entendu qui dit avoir recours aux marins
pompiers pour effectuer des prélèvements
à la surface des eaux usées pour
détecter notamment cette fameuse
variante du virus faire avoir recours
aux marins pompiers c'est une
spécificité pour marseille à ce qui pose
la question en france pour le dispositif
faut-il déployé l'armée selon vous comme
c'est le cas notamment en israël ou en
allemagne
on a beaucoup d'autres services qui sont
aussi je pense en mesure d'aider à
lutter dans cette crise il ya les
pompiers sur le reste du territoire
il y à la sécurité civile les armées ont
un dispositif est un service médical
mais qui est déjà
particulièrement exemple et qui a à
gérer beaucoup plus finalement de
problèmes qu'il n'en a les moyens au
jour d'aujourd'hui je pense donc qu'on
peut effectivement se poser la question
de la mobilisation des forces vives en
fonction bien évidemment de leurs
compétences pour accompagner les
soignants dans la gestion de cette crise
s'est il faut évidemment profité des
savoir-faire et des compétences de
chacun ont mené ce combat il est
d'ailleurs peut-être un peu navrant de
voir qu'on a attendu tant pour se poser
les bonnes questions
alors oui verront on le voit fait tout
pour accélérer le pas ce week end on a
dépassé le cap des cent mille français
vaccinés olivier ferrand qui maintient
son objectif d'un million de français
vaccinés d'ici à la fin du mois vous y
croyez
quand on prend les chiffres de ces
dernières semaines qu'on voit le volume
de 25 que l'on reçoit quotidiennement
ça me paraît difficile on s'aperçoit
encore une fois qu'on nous raconte une
histoire et que le lendemain pour des
questions d'opportunité ou de
communication il nous a raconté une
autre il fallait quatre semaines entre
les deux injections puisqu'on n'a pas de
vaccin on va essayer de faire un peu de
cavalerie sur les stocks et on nous dit
qu'il faudra finalement six semaines
entre les deux injections
honnêtement techniquement à la vitesse
où va la vaccination
je l'espère parce que je pense que c'est
dans notre intérêt à tous de parvenir à
un plus grand nombre de vaccinés sur le
territoire mais j'ai du mal à y croire
la maire de paris a fustigé ce retard à
l'allumage de l'exécutif ce week-end
avec de telles carences dit anne hidalgo
honoraires à tel débarquement de 44
écoutez je ne remets pas en question
l'ordre de vaccination établi qu'ils
commencent par les plus fragiles mais je
ne comprends toujours pas le retard à
l'allumage
avec de telles carences le débarquement
de juin 1944
or et échoué c'est un jugement assez
sévère est ce que vous le partagez
je pense qu'on aurait pu puisqu'on
savait que le vaccin allait finir par
arriver réfléchir très en amont à la
politique vaccinale est la façon des
procédés on aurait peut-être aussi pu
compte tenu de la gravité de la crise et
vitré éviter d'entrer dans des
négociations sur le prix d'achat du
vaccin est immédiatement pour procéder à
des commandes comme l'ont fait certains
autres pays pour être livrés
prioritairement et non pas les
commandants bilatérales c'est ce que
vous dites oui on en a on était pas on
n'était pas obligé d'entrer dans ces
négociations il ya une urgence si elle
le demande mondiale de ce vaccin
on savait très bien que les premiers
arrivés seront les premiers servis
et je pense aussi qu'on a perdu du temps
dans la gestion de l'acquisition des
vaccins une question sur ce fameux
variant britannique est arrivé à
marseille on sait que c'est une une
française qui est revenu en france pour
les fêtes ça pose la question de la
fermeture des frontières à ce moment là
on savait très bien que le virus
le vario anglais était sur le territoire
est ce qu'il ya eu un an que selon vous
dans une faille en tout cas dans la
précaution dû à ce virus en france c'est
compliqué parce qu'on sait très bien
qu'une fermeture hermétique et totale
des frontières dans le monde dans lequel
on vit quelque chose de totalement
impossible à faire et et à gérer on a un
virus qui circulent on doit tous être
prudent une fermeture totale des
frontières
objectivement et matériellement ça me
paraîtrait impossible une mise en
quarantaine
c'est ce qu'avait fait la grande
bretagne souvenez vous allaitez l'été
dernier dans le bon sens inverse c'est
c'est l'un des gros problèmes de la
france dans la gestion de la crise celle
isolement des personnes déclarées
positives testée positive et qu'on ne
prend finalement en compte parce que
quand on isole quinquin chez lui ou dans
un foyer où vivent 3 4 ou 5 personnes
finalement les halls pas et on s'est
peut-être pas effectivement poser les
bonnes questions et me poser la question
de la gestion de cet isolement des cas
positifs ou des possibles quarantaine
pour les cas positifs alors on va
écouter à présent le ministre la santé
qui a répondu
anne hidalgo quand elle parle d'un
débarquement raté en 44 pour lui c'est
un coup de com écouter certains élus qui
ne sont pas forcément des présidents de
région sortants certains maires de
grandes villes qui sont peut-être dans
l'idée dans l'espoir ou dans le fantasme
d'une campagne en profite pour se faire
un coup de com alors il en profite pour
faire un coup de com est-ce que c'est
pas le cas aussi un peu du du
gouvernement dans ce virus qui va
prendre en tout cas une part importante
dans les débats avant les régionales je
vais vous dire que voir le ministre de
la santé reproché à certains élus de
faire des coups de com alors qu'il ne
passe lui-même séjour n'est qu'affaire
de la communication rappelez vous où
j'ai l'esprit cet épisode lors du
dernier texte sur l'état d'urgence que
nous avons voté où il avait préféré
aller visiter un hôpital avec d'ailleurs
toutes les contraintes que sa pose et
tout le blocage du fonctionnement de
l'hôpital quand il ya une visite
ministérielle plutôt que d'être dans
l'hémicycle avec nous pour discuter de
l'avenir des français donc je dois
avouer je suis pas certain qu'ils soient
le mieux placé pour faire ce genre de
critiques
un mot sur le personnel hospitalier si
vous le voulez bien de nouveau en grève
illimitée à partir d'aujourd'hui à cause
du ségur de la santé qui a supprimé
trois échelons dans la grille salariale
ce qui crée selon des des inégalités
entre praticiens hospitaliers
emmanuel macron a promis de rendre
l'hôpital public attractif est ce que
c'est en bonne voie selon vous j'en suis
j'en suis lasse pas j'en suis lasse pas
certain et je ne suis également pas
certain que leur implication et leur
dévouement dans la gestion de cette
crise depuis maintenant près d'un an
soit pris sa juste valeur gens contre
moi même quantité demandée des médecins
sur le terrain et des médecins
hospitaliers et ce que l'on me dit c'est
que les chefs de service me disent c'est
que finalement un chaque jour il voit
des médecins quitter le monde
hospitalier
plutôt qu y rester et c'est à partir du
moment où quitte le seul lieu dans
lequel on exerce sa fonction c'est que
forcément il ya un problème notre
activité merci beaucoup antoine savinien
d'avoir répondu ce matin en direct
question sur rt france rappelle que vous
êtes député les républicains du val
d'oise